red dead redemption 2 is rockstar's most
ambitious game to date with nearly 20
years of experience in almost 30 games
under its belt it's clear that the
studio is pulling from its rich history
in order to make its biggest game
yet eight rockstar studios around the
globe are putting bits and pieces of its
history into this project and based on
what we've seen so far
it shows let's take a look back at some
of rockstar's biggest games from the
last 15 years and see where they fit in
with red dead redemption
2.
[Music]
welcome home carl glad to be back
you haven't forgotten about us have you
boy hell no officer 10 penny i was just
wondering what took y'all so long
get in the car let's turn the clock back
to 2004.
rachel got off the plane we started
stalking people we know and we lost our
lives to gta san
andreas developed by rockstar north it
was the biggest game the studio had ever
shipped
alongside a sprawling map with three
distinct cities
san andreas allowed you to morph cj's
body as you played
for example if you gorged yourself on
meat stacks at burger shot
cj would start to get plump conversely
if you ate healthy and hit the gym every
now and then
cj would get buff if only it were that
easy in real life
an in-shape cj would garner more respect
and have greater sex appeal while a
chubbier cj would have less luck with
the ladies
as unique as this mechanic was at the
time rockstar has not revisited it and
any subsequent games until now
like cj arthur morgan will change and
evolve depending on how you play
your beard and hair will grow over time
if you don't get a trim you can even
make yourself look sharp by slicking
that dew back
if you overindulge arthur will put on
some weight and even deride himself when
he catches his reflection in mirrors
and if you don't clean yourself every
now and then arthur will start to get
stanky
npcs and gang members will respond to
arthur differently depending on his
hygiene and personal upkeep
even taking him aside to suggest that he
should wash himself
[Music]
you've done a lot of naughty things
haven't you vandalism
graffiti bad language violent conduct
disrespecting staff
oh i'm scared of you hopkins come on
give me a break
yes i've never met a boy like you never
in all my life
hopkins you're quite the nastiest little
boy i have ever encountered
tell me why should i waste my time on
you i don't know
because it's my calling it's what i do
you excel at causing trouble and i excel
at fixing little boys like you
let's move on to one of my favorite
rockstar games of all time
bully bully was a unique take on the
open world genre
it was a much more intimate experience
bulworth academy and the surrounding
areas were smaller than a city
there were no guns and if you were a
good student you'd be spending a lot of
time in class
but the scope no matter how narrow it
was compared to gta
was the right fit bully became an
influential addition to rockstar's
catalog in its own right
one of bully's more interesting parts
was the way you could interact with npcs
you could greet them either positively
or negatively
you could talk your way out of trouble
and even apologize to someone you'd
injured
while it wasn't as fleshed out as it
could have been it did allow you to
respond to social situations in unique
ways
rockstar briefly revisited this mechanic
in red dead redemption where a tap of a
button allowed john to tip his hat to
those around him but now rockstar is
expanding this mechanic in red dead
redemption 2.
if you target an npc without your gun
equipped you are given a handful of
social interactions
you can greet threaten or rob an npc
depending on how they respond to arthur
he can continue the conversation or just
walk away
based on the first several hours this
adds another layer of complexity to the
world
npcs feature a wider range of attitudes
towards you
they aren't all either simply docile or
shooting at you
you can defuse encounters in ways you
see fit
[Music]
two things you remember during the war
we did some bad things and bad things
happened to us
war is where the young and stupid are
tricked by the old and bitter into
killing each other
i was very young and very angry
maybe that is no excuse
roman ramen
are you sleeping you're fat come on
grand theft auto 4 was a bit of a
departure from previous entries in the
franchise
many of the features from san andreas
and bully had disappeared
and the over-the-top tone was replaced
with a more realistic one gone were the
jet packs and planes of san andreas and
the warm weather of vice city
and while some players lamented the loss
of this wackiness rockstar replaced it
with something just as important
a strong sense of place liberty city
felt alive
you could follow npcs going about their
business and nico could just hang out
and befriend key characters
since gta 4 rockstar has opted for the
most part to create more grounded and
realistic experiences that offer a
strong sense of place
gta 4's vision of a more realistic take
on the open world genre can be seen
in nearly all of rockstar's subsequent
games and is pushed much further than
before
in red dead redemption 2.
for every cop there's the case that
makes you
gives you that leg up gets you
recognized as a shining new star on the
squad the case that you solved that
shows that you have the gumption
the gun hole that get up and go to make
you stand out from your average rank and
file patrolmen
this could be the one goal la noir was
an unusual game for rockstar and its
developer team bondi
combat was put on the back burner in
favor of a slower paced experience that
asked you to carefully explore
crime scenes gather evidence and
question witnesses
not everyone loved it but to this day
there are still few games like it
one of the key mechanics is the ability
to examine and manipulate objects found
in the environment in order to piece
together how the crime went down
la noir wasn't the first game to do this
and it certainly won't be the last but
it's the only rockstar game to date that
allowed you to interact with the
environment to this extent
red dead redemption 2 aims to do
something similar while you may not be
solving cases
arthur morgan can pick up certain
objects in the environment and examine
them as you would in la noire
instead of exploring the wild frontier
you might find yourself holed up in a
house examining pictures and notes left
by previous residents
so i guess i'd become what they wanted
me to be
a killer some rent-a-clown with a gun
who puts holes in other bad
guys well that's what they had paid for
so in the end that's what they got say
what you want about americans
but we understand capitalism you buy
yourself a product and you get what you
pay
for and these chumps had paid for some
angry gringo without the sensibilities
to know right from wrong
max payne 3 was a bold game while i
wouldn't call it realistic
i mean come on you hang from a
helicopter and shoot rockets out of the
sky
its mechanics make it feel like one of
rockstar's most grounded experiences to
date
if max takes a bullet to the head he
goes down immediately
even on the easiest difficulty but what
stood out to me more was how rockstar
handled weapon management
max's inventory was limited he could
only carry as many guns as he had hands
and holsters
this means that if you were using a
pistol and had a rifle max would carry
the rifle in his other hand
if you decided to dual wield handguns
max would toss his rifle on the ground
even the reload animations were
different depending on which weapons max
had in his hands
rockstar's following game gta 5 may have
brought back the infinite item pockets
but red dead redemption 2
won't every weapon arthur carries
appears on his body
this means you can only take a few
weapons with you into a firefight the
rest of your firearms are stored in your
saddlebag
weapon management isn't the only thing
red dead redemption 2 borrows from max
payne 3.
at the end of a firefight in max payne
you would be treated to a gruesome slow
motion kill cam
if you're into that sort of thing you'll
be happy to know that this feature is
going to return in red dead redemption 2
and it will change based on your
morality
if you're a good cowboy the killcams
will look more heroic and if you're a
villainous cowboy they will be gorier
[Music]
if you want my advice give the [ __ ] up
you work hard screw over everybody that
you love
hurt rob kill indiscriminately
and maybe just maybe if you're lucky you
become a three bit gangster
it's [ __ ] go to college
you can rip people off and get paid for
it
it's called capitalism to know in
surprise red dead redemption 2 expands
on many of gta 5's mechanics
a notable example is stat building as
you play gta 5
trevor michael and franklin's stats
would increase in logical ways
if you swam a lot your lung capacity
would increase if you drove everywhere
your driving skill would increase
and so on red dead redemption 2 takes a
similar approach with arthur's skills
the more you run the better your stamina
gets the more you shoot the more your
sharp shooting increases
gta 5 was also one of the first rockstar
games to support a first person camera
it offered a radically different feel to
gta and it's returning for red dead
redemption 2.
if you want you can play the whole game
in first person from beginning to end
red dead redemption 2 even allows you to
tweak the first person camera settings
to your liking but remember just because
you can't see arthur doesn't mean that
he shouldn't bathe every now and then
[Music]
[Music]
grand theft auto online is a different
beast for rockstar while plenty of its
games support multiplayer gta online is
far
bigger and far deeper than anything the
studio had released previously
it built off the open world structure of
red dead redemption's multiplayer
players can purchase property build out
their garages with exotic supercars and
even start their own businesses
and of course it has plenty of
cooperative and competitive missions and
game types to participate in
to this day rockstar still releases free
updates for gta online and it continues
to be a massive source of income for the
studio
we don't know much about red dead
redemption 2's online component yet but
it sounds like it will be building off
gta
online according to an interview ign did
with a few of the devs you will once
again be able to explore a massive world
as a cowboy or cowgirl and partake in
different missions and competitive game
modes
unlike gta online the slower pace of red
dead redemption 2
might elevate the more intimate moments
that arise despite this
it sounds like fans of gta online should
feel comfortable with red dead online
it's worth noting that like gta online
it won't be available until a few weeks
after red dead redemption 2
launches
rockstar has made a habit of creating
ambitious games and in almost all cases
succeeded in realizing its ambitions red
dead redemption 2
is shaping up to be a celebration of
that success a game that leverages the
design experience it has accumulated
from developing games across multiple
franchises and
genres if it all comes together as
intended it could be a landmark release
in video game history
though it is missing one thing
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more red dead videos like this
come back every friday to catch our new
show
quick draw we have a lot of in-depth
videos planned for before and after the
game comes out that you don't want to
[Music]
miss